can you imagine taking a test and not
getting the results for 40 years
how tough is that i mean in high school
in college you go take a test the next
day you find out if you failed or passed
right
but parenting is the only test you take
that you will not find that
whether you did good or not for 40.
years today
i was asked to share with you how i'm
raising my kids
whether this stuff's going to work or
not i'm not going to know for 40 years
but i'm going to share with you some of
the methods
i'm deciding to raise my kids hoping
they're going to be successful
[Music]
all right so let's get right into a look
parenting is like public speaking a lot
of people
in the world of sales they're very good
at from stage i'm a very good public
speaker let's just say right and then
some are good
in groups of three to five or ten like a
smaller group talking to people right
but the best leaders i know they're the
best at one on one
and parenting is all one-on-one meaning
you can sit there with your three kids
and give them a pep talk collectively
together right you can sit there and
give them a
spiel or preach something at them right
but there's nothing more powerful to me
in parenting than one-on-one the best
conversations i've ever had with my dad
nobody else was around it was just he
and i the best conversation i'm willing
to bet that you have with your mom or
your dad
were probably just you and them when it
comes down to raising kids i read a book
a long time
time ago saying thank god it's monday
meaning i can't wait to get away from my
family the author who's a
therapist said one of the best ways to
save your marriage and parenting
is to spend one-on-one time
communicating with your individual kids
and your spouse uh i've taken the
philosophy of talking to my kids
one on one to see what's on their mind
and address whatever issue they have and
if it's got to be something where you
got to discipline them
if the level of discipline is higher
where you got to be really serious
conversation with them
pull them aside to have that
conversation with them one-on-one they
will appreciate it at least i did
balancing between competition and
teamwork let me explain to what i mean
by this a lot of people will say parents
will say
it is not good to raise your kids
competitive that's their philosophy
it's not mine so i'll give you an
example of what happened to us
just last sunday so we every sunday we
bike with me and my kids and
it's between eight to twelve miles with
a bike right with my nine-year-old and
my seven year we'll get on the bike and
boom we'll go out there with a bike
typically i'll say hey dad i if i win
this first batch
i want to get slurpee when i come back i
want to be able to play 30 minutes more
video games i want to be able to do
xyz so great no problem so they'll
compete against each other
because it's friendly competition
they're around the same age one of them
is stronger obviously
but it's still healthy competition but
on the way back i said here's what we're
going to be doing today says what's that
i said today i want to see both of you
work together as a team to see if both
of you together can beat me by working
as a team and motivating each other see
if you can beat me so i'm now on the
bike pulling my daughter and she's in
the back
and we're going and they're in front of
me i'm not gonna lie to you i showed up
and i mean i'm sweating so bad my dad's
like what happened to you
i am drenched because they were willing
to work
collectively together to have a common
enemy which was who
let's be daddy and they did that they
both i'm proud of them
if you see this one day you were seven
or nine years old when you beat daddy
but i
i there's a balance of both i don't mind
hey let's see who's going to be able to
do this lap faster okay great now let's
see how you guys can do it together
you know so competition and teamwork if
i have to choose between the two which
one a little bit more than the other i'm
probably going to be 51
teamwork 49 competition but i'm driving
both
next one is something i do in our family
a lot and that is debate i love debate
what i mean by debate is any topic that
comes up
patrick's reading the book and i'll say
so do you think that was the right thing
to do when they're doing this i don't
know if it's the right thing to
why do you think i think this i think
that why not what if they did this but
that why would they do this well because
they did this
is that a bad idea who said it's a bad
idea and we're
constantly debating and they'll be
talking to each other what do you think
about it what do you think about it
i think we should do this why do you
think we should go to the movies i think
we need to go to the movies because of
this
why do you think we i think we should
play outside why should we play outside
because if we play outside we spend more
time to get in the movies it's quiet and
we're just sitting there together
and we're all quiet for like five
seconds okay then let's go play outside
right but it's the muscle of debating
because their brain is learning how to
reason
by constantly challenging each other's
mind and you'd be amazed
at what age kids can debate it's very
very early
and i think it's something that
strengthens their mind to be able to
make help make better decisions as they
age next one is
you know teaching them independence
rather than doing everything for them
like a lot of times you know
a grandma or grandfather a father or a
mother sometimes parents want to do
everything for their kids oh
publicito i want to do everything for
you it's okay i got this for it's okay i
got that for you it's okay it's okay
no it's it's allowing these kids to have
to figure out their problems like let's
just say they're going through something
and one of my kids will come up to me
and there's a bully situation going on i
would say so then what do you think
about what happened that you were there
i think you should have done this okay
what what do you think
yeah but but here's what was going on
how do you think you guys could have
solved that together
we would have been able to do it this
way okay can you guys do it or do you
need my help no daddy let us do it first
let us do it first we got it daddy let
us do it first let us do it first
we got the study i got it i got it i got
it i got it
let us do it first you're teaching an
element of independence because
long term you and i got 18 years to
teach these kids to be 18
independent one day leave you one day if
you don't teach them independent
they're going to be having a very hard
time in this
life because this place is not the
friendliest place today especially today
they have to learn how to be independent
be strong at the same time
and know how to make the right decisions
and avoid the wrong decisions god knows
they're going to make some wrong
decisions you got to give a little bit
of leeway
but the more you allow them to make the
decisions eventually their
decision-making machine will get better
use because i said so very rarely
meaning
use that as something in your pocket to
use once in a while
because i said so every day the other
day i went to a church
and this one lady's next to me and her
son has not listened to her
he's like you know what i'm just going
to go give him a weapon because he's
going to listen to me and she just went
and bam give her one the son cried and
also
because i said so because i said so i've
said because i said so
but i use that card very rarely and i
keep it here so you can use it anytime
as a parent it's your card you own it
you can say because i said so but there
are there are
alternatives too because i said so was
one time talking to
a a gentleman who talked about reagan
and i don't know who this person was
that i it could have been a larry yarn
but he explained reagan as the great
explainer
he said the reason why american voters
liked reagan because he explained things
so well
sometimes as parents we don't explain
enough we don't say
here's what i want you to do go do it no
here's what i want you to do
here's why if you don't add the why
you're a dictator
you don't want to be a dictator all the
time i understand sometimes as a family
as a parent you have to put your foot
down and make the decision and call the
shots
and move with it but try to become a
better explainer to your kids
where you're teaching them how to reason
by you reasoning
with them eventually it'll create a
better relationship with them
choose the right movies to watch with
your kids i'm a big movie guy myself and
i love choosing the right movies to
watch with them so we have this game
that we
we take turns every time he has a movie
then he has a movie
then she has a movie then it's my turn
every time it comes to me to pick a
movie my movies have lessons behind them
so then it's like oh my gosh here we go
they start off now i like the movie
at the end guess what they end up loving
them every single time i pick a movie
no i don't want to watch remember the
titans
please daddy wow daddy i love this movie
i don't want to watch walk the line
johnny cash
why is this a two and a half hour movie
and then they say
wow it makes sense so johnny cash walked
the line phenomenal movie i watched with
the kids
a couple weeks ago and there's a couple
parts in that movie one is that the
movie teaches about
drugs teaches about the wrong friends
teaches you about a father that's
abusive and alcoholic and the power of
what alcohol does to ruin families
it teaches you so many different things
where you know persistence if you love
somebody persistent say june marry me
june marry me june marry me june and
patience and family working together and
brother
you know the brother left and the other
brother was left by himself and the
accident that happens to johnny cash's
brother
felt now i can't believe that you guys
got to work together as a team never
leave your body alone
there's so many messages to it remember
the titans daddy what's the big deal if
whites get on one truck one
bus and blacks i said that's not a big
deal we all have to work together we're
brown we're around you're middle eastern
and you're white what are you talking
about we're not black we're not white
we're brown we're confused
you got a white mom who married a middle
eastern dad so we're like
a little bit of everything okay so but
why is it such a it's not a big deal why
look how they work together look what
happened look what happened when he got
injured they still have to come back you
still have to win you start to figure
out a way
to do it for the right people oh my this
is such a great guy i love this story
so choose the right movies i have a list
of movies that i go through with my kids
that's a long list of movies that i'm
going
through with my kids i'm unlike movie
number 10 right now but each of them
have a lesson make a list of movies with
the right lessons to teach them
and start watching a movie and pause
here's what happened here what do you
think about what happened what you
thought whatever you were talking about
what do you think about what just
happened over here
well why did this happen process it with
them so yes make a list of movies and
watch it with them while processing it
with them
all your kids are going to be different
that was different my sister is
different my kids are different they're
all different it's very weird how
different they are and
sometimes you if you have three kids
you're typically gonna have one that's
gonna be very reasonable
meaning one kid that you have very easy
time doing business with everything is
so easy with this kid just
teachers love them school loves them
friends love them everybody loves them
it's just
a breath of pressure to deal with this
kid you're gonna have another kid that's
gonna be able to get away with stuff
like oh this person they know how to
kind of get away with things look at the
way
she does this or he does is look at this
they're very good and you kind of like i
know what you're doing
but they get away with it anyway because
they're charming like you have that one
seducer right
and then you're gonna have a kid that's
gonna be very difficult
right one of the worst things you will
ever do with kids is compare them
constantly why can't you be like this
person i hate it here why can't you be
like that friend
why can't you be like this i'm like dude
i am not like everybody i'm very
different than everybody
so the first time one of my kids had
experienced that in school and he came
back and said they call me
weird they call me different they call
me this um
i said my entire life here that's that
is that's been called weird so
and we had a conversation together so
you know
try to do your best like in the game of
business leading sales people leading
people period
you're always going to have someone
that's going to be your best producer
that's easy to work with
but you're also going to have some
people that are not you got to figure
out a way to lead
people regardless of their personalities
and do your best to adjust to lead that
kid
not the same way that you lead this kid
and that kid
because they're all going to have
different personalities and different
motivators
create a currency in your house and what
i mean by currency in your house is
what is valuable for them to get in
return from you what they want so
some homes that's you got to clean the
house you got to clean this you got to
clean that you got to clean this
you're essentially teaching your kids to
be cleaners right which is fine but
you're teaching them
to do that i want to incentivize
like to me chores are things you're
supposed to do right
you don't get currency on chores there
is no currency on collect your lego
clean it up on
can i get five dollars for cleaning this
no that's what you're supposed to do i
don't want them to think
you get paid five dollars for cleaning
the floor because later on they're
adults cleaning the four because when
they were seven years old
daddy paid the money i'm not doing that
we're not doing that that's a chore
let's go clean it up right
you go read a book okay you finish a
book how many pages you read
20 perfect 20 points that's your
currency
if you want to get a video game it's 400
points great that's 400 pages oh let me
go read 400 pages
it's a method of currency exercise
currency reading the book currency
whatever
it is to whatever currency you decide as
a family husband and wife or you're by
yourself
whatever currency you decide your kids
are going to like it more
if they have a set of clear expectation
of what to do to get xyz
one kid's gonna want to go to disneyland
for a day phenomenal
create the currency he's got to read 20
books 80 books 40 books i don't care
what it is
but they have to do something once that
set of clarity is there
you'd be amazed how much more your kids
will perform because it's very
predictable currency that's being used
in your house instead of one day it's
this one day it's this one day says one
day
and eventually they're like ah mom i'm
down i don't care do whatever you want
to do
they won't take you seriously create a
very consistent currency for everybody
ask your kids for their opinions i ask
it from a very early age it doesn't
matter what it is
so how was the food what did you think
about the food i thought it was okay
what did you think about the service
here i thought it was good what do you
think about basketball versus football
i don't know i think about this you know
mommy
is uh you know going through cooking
something what should i cook what do you
think we should cook what do you think
mommy should put together for us
let's go eat at a restaurant what do you
guys want to go eat how about we go here
huh okay
what do you think what do you think what
do you think what do you think what do
you think is constant
that imagine if your brain is a muscle
like
what do you think what do you think
you're developing this muscle to think
what do you think
right i probably if you would ask the
people that work around me non-stop my
board my employees my executives my
directors my staff my family my wife my
friends
everybody they would tell you pat asks
us what do you think all the damn time
i'm always asking what do you think what
are your thoughts
because i want to hear what you're
thinking then we process it together and
it's a method of building leaders
of the people that are around you so
this next one i almost have to explain
it to you here's what i mean by it so
as a parent say we got a barometer here
right
on this side you're a bad parent on this
side you're a great parent both of them
have a problem okay there's consequences
for both of them right
if you're a bad parent your kids are
gonna be what either they're gonna say i
never wanna be like mommy when i grow up
i never wanna be like daddy when i grow
up or they're gonna be just like you
you just like you right that's why they
say generational curse is like hey what
can you do to stop gender if you're
somebody that's always
drinking every night your kids see you
drinking every single night you're
fighting with your wife your face like
that that's a bad example if they have
to see it every single day right you're
away
constantly leaving constantly fights
constantly bickering not taking care of
yourself lazy
no money mom and dad always fighting
there's always issues because one's not
working hard
that you know who you are if it's great
or bad right you may say i'm a good
example you may see a great example
great example is
you're winning at the highest level
where your problem is you're creating a
shadow
so here's here you got it different
issues let me tell you the
issues here if you're somebody that is a
great example you wouldn't get the
highest level in career and life
well you have two issues one of them is
you have unnecessary shadows that you're
creating
unnecessary expectation that you're
creating right
the other one is what when you do so
much and you win a lot of times parents
who worked so hard to win at the highest
level
they're afraid to have their kids pay
the same price so they they raise
soft kids so weird sometimes parents who
work very hard to win at the highest
level they end up raising soft kids
because they make the kids life so much
easier and they take that opportunity
away
of the kid also fighting for it so take
this barometer
if you're a bad parent and you didn't
necessarily set the best example
let's just say and you're like well i
didn't do that well you're trying to do
your best but it wasn't the best example
you gotta inject belief constantly you
gotta let them know
you can be better than daddy you can do
great things you can go out there and do
good why don't you be the leader i want
you you can do that and then you have to
work on your example because at any
point you can go from bad
to okay to good to great you need to
maybe work on being a better example as
a parent as parents you know we're
we're flawed human beings we have a lot
of issues we have a lot of vices we have
our own set of challenges some is
alcohol some it's
gambling some it's bad money issues some
it's health some is argument some it's
word some it's again
we have so many issues ourselves because
we are also trying to figure ourselves
out in this life without a manual right
we're trying to figure out this life
manual that we have so
you have to work on going over here and
you got to inject a lot of belief if
you're somebody that's winning at the
highest level
don't compare your kids to you don't
create unnecessary
expectation for them that they don't
necessarily need and don't let others do
it
like let's just say if a friend of yours
comes and says well you're going to be
a good you know you got a great daddy
let's see if you can do what he did no
no stop him right
i'm sorry he's not his daddy he's his
own man he's his own kid
you know we're going to see what he's
going to be doing what i like about him
is he likes this
right in front of there you got to nip
it in the butt because or else other
people think they can say that kind of
stuff to your kid
and it creates a division between you
and your kid so for me my suggestion for
you would be
self-deprecation spend a lot of time
deprecating yourself
let me tell you about the mistakes daddy
made let me tell you about the mistakes
mommy made
don't spend too much time talking about
the things you did right if you talk
20 percent of the time about things you
did right 80 percent of the time
talk about the things you did wrong not
right
because that brings the pressure a
little bit lower for them to perform
better
just like in golf you don't scare the
hell out of somebody right before they
hit a shot
you got to figure out a way to teach
them how to come here so they hit the
ball better right
you're trying to get your kids to come
here so they make better decisions
if it's constant shadow unexpected you
know unfair
expectations of trying to be like you
these kids
are gonna eventually resent you and
there'll be a five ten fifteen year
period of them wanting to be away from
you because it's constantly being
compared
to mommy or daddy and it's flat out
unfair to do so so if you got a lot of
value from today's video i got two other
videos i want you to be thinking about
one of the videos is 15 types of parents
to find out which one you are
and which one you were raised by if
you've now watched us click over here
and the other one is
15 things to know before you date an
entrepreneur meaning if you're an
entrepreneur you're about to date
somebody maybe they ought to watch this
video and if you're somebody that's
about to date an entrepreneur
it's probably a good idea you know how
they're wired because they're not like
everybody else
having said that if you enjoyed today's
episode click that subscribe button take
care everybody bye